this is story for Stan um hopefully this
is the right order cuz I'm looking at
Wikipedia and I'm looking at Amazon
Amazon hasn't like 100% backwards this
is really slanted yeah sorry um but yeah
so this is the story of how Stephens dad
met Stephens mom and this manager that's
any How I Met Your Mother
only for writing yeah 15 minutes long
without a shitty ending um I do even
know the ending of the show I just know
everybody hates the end I the ending of
the shows about okay I think I maybe
seen a dozen episodes cuz my wife like
that
I hear so much you - yeah like
heavy having not seen the whole show I
still somehow knew that this ending blew
like I'm just like wait a second I got I
got the right I had to keep asking my
wife questions I'm just like so it's
been following these two people all
along but she's like yes I'm like that
makes no sense and she's like an you
didn't even watch the show uh but anywho
we're talking about this one uh and the
manager who seemed relatively pointless
I mean the story supposed to be about
him and it's read about it it's how they
met and it's like really a douche bag
yeah he just seems like a totally
pointless douche bag character who's
barely in it which I didn't mind because
he's so unlikable but the only thing I
can figure is maybe they're gonna bring
him back for something he's gonna come
back as an enemy but yeah just think of
the whole thing I'm like you gotta cut
him out pretty easily it's like well
it's about you know I'll tell you this
version but now I'll tell you the
version with my manager in it and it's
like I I think you could tell the
version without the manager honestly I
don't think we miss that much um but
yeah so yeah I guess maybe the point is
sometimes even idiots and jerks find
ways to steer you towards happiness ya
know there's there's it's it's possible
um when uh the cool stuff about I mean
it's nice to see the meet I'm actually
the two things I see so rarely done well
are you know is horror at like
legitimately scary or and
romance like legitimately hey I feel
something for these two people romance
so when I see something do it relatively
well and I I like it um it does seem
like again kind of a disney ism like
he's just ready to throw everything for
this woman like he just met um but again
I think that's kind of like just the
kids show angle um but I don't know I
would like to see it develop a little
bit more but I
they had chemistry which I like I like
it when these two people meet and they
have this chemistry um you know giving
up your whole life for it that's a
different story but um but I do like
when they have chemistry so and we got
to see more of the gems clearly before
they know anything about people they
call them it um and amethyst looks like
howdy it looks like yeah I like how they
all seemed younger even though pearl had
kind of a different hairstyle yeah the
80s yeah amethyst amethyst seemed
younger yeah garnet looked pretty much
the same but look like maybe she had
slightly different hair yeah but what
and I like their even more I mean we
always talk about how impressive they
are to anything new you see even to
humans that you know squash it throw it
back over the fence you know get rid of
it you know and they're just so hostile
against them um which again is just so
interesting it was my favorite little
moment was when a rose was just like
spaces his like gimmick like yeah I'm
pearl what haha they think they
know about space well and even then you
sort of see kind of like that jealousy
starting to you know I could sing you
know they all kind of laugh um so again
there's already a little bit of that
hostility starting between them well hey
isn't that interesting - okay so
amethyst now is since we see she was a
kid around that point you know whatever
they wherever they took her off
literally um you know at a younger age
so maybe when Stevens dead and her were
hanging out like she was still a kid
which will make the connection even more
it's their first crush baby I don't know
or even kind of like an almost father
figure or something like that cuz again
we don't know I didn't like it hard
Chael because I have to remind myself
how huge roses like I'm not really
talking about with just her height yeah
so that when they tell me of them yeah
when all of them were together like
amethyst seems so small but then I don't
know like I'd have to go to this yeah
she's art if she had she still Twitter
she's kind of hiding behind pearl pearl
kind of carries her and stuff well it
definitely yeah yeah I can't get the aid
I don't know if it's why I always forget
how tall Rose is like when they're all
together like Jesus what would I like to
this is the first time we've seen Rose
like actually like hey we're gonna show
you what she said in the scene it's not
like hey here's a videocassette here's a
hologram projection or anything like
that it's here's what she was actually
saying and doing in Stowe which is kind
of nice
exactly I mean it's not like Stevens dad
was telling this so it was all from his
point of view okay it's still very much
there's no there's no other kind of
filter there in terms of like what
you're visually seeing or I know a man
oh you mean oh also it's wasn't mirrors
that opening song like that was nice
that's a nice song this just like is I
was almost in a strange way hoping this
was gonna be one long views yeah that's
what's hoping to like the whole thing
was just gonna not like what it went
went to the straight-laced kind of show
part I'm just like that's cool and all
but I yeah what a bit cool unveils a
song I mean we would have like done the
song ya know I mean it's like that's
that's a lot of work I'm not gonna be
like what's wrong with you lazy it's
like no no I get it that's a lot of work
um but yeah I actually really
legitimately like that opening song um
and I mean it looks like you know it's
in the 80s I mean it looks pretty
eighties ish or you know maybe early 90s
but I don't know the hairstyles and
stuff still look pretty 80s so I mean
that would indicate even more I mean cuz
obviously tiny pass rate well I mean
yeah but here's the thing Stevens only
what twelve something like that but
again we don't even know did he like we
don't know buddy or whatever but but
okay you look at the father though I
mean he's balding so years have passed
and
days about the amount of time we present
I yeah but I don't
but if he's 12 that means he well how
long did they know each other before
they had Stephen like yesterday Stephen
could be born at that age or could be
made at that age and because it's half
Rho is just kind of doing whatever she
wants you know so I don't know I it
doesn't seem like they've established
where crime of chronological II this is
like I kind of just feel like one
doesn't the father they believe that's a
thing I mean he's obviously not super
old he's balding and stuff but he's not
super old so I mean the 80s I mean it
seems like again the present time or
like ten years from something like that
from present time I mean here's the
problem I get a vague eighties feeling
from the entire show so it's hard to be
like oh well that's the 80s and this is
president I mean the whole thing is like
a pan 80s 70s kind of color scheme and
character design and like so and I I
don't know if it's really saying when
and where this is supposed to take place
like I mean if I mean maybe it says
somewhere true it's 2015 or I Met Your
Mother in 1985 like a puppet you're kind
of right like even the the styles and
the fashion it's like it looks 80s but
you're right that could be the ad level
very much Tamils English anyway a night
seventies yeah yeah like literally
probably like 1980 or 81 like still in
that 70s kind of like it's got that
old-school vibe to all of the character
like design and backgrounds and I mean
like kind of like the rock band heavy
metal and stuff like that I mean that
Bell is looking like mid 80s at Lee for
him um so but you're right everything
else our hands like a 70s 80s kinda
nineties feel to I'm even going specific
for the 80s but I don't know if it
you're right they never specifically say
cuz with this time period took away
creators and the animators and the story
writer is maybe going when eighties
because that's when they grew up but I
mean I I don't think it's ever
specifically said not word in the 80s
well you know where wherever they're
traveling it's earth it's you know
because they say they never leave the
galaxy do anything right you know all
those places are on earth so you know
either they're finding these places that
for some reason
are uncharted or something has happened
to earth you know so that's what I'm
curious about
um but yeah it is again all these little
clues and stuff like that uh - a puzzle
I'm not smart enough to put together yet
um but yeah I mean I liked its nicey
more rows in it it's um it's nice seeing
a little bit more Stephens dad when he
was younger and stuff so I got way more
plot in this where Rosen was concerned
like yeah so I totally appreciate that
um and it's interesting you wonder why
she showed up to that concert at all
since she was the only one um well they
were on the beach she may have just been
standing outside on a cigarette break or
something been like says she's smoking a
rose flower or something um but uh that
looks like fun but uh wouldn't be gravy
hello like Rose just this really nice
beautiful design ever the edgy sounds
like it's just a man yeah got a day
wonderful pick something out of the
critic I'm up to 12 bags a day um but uh
yeah I have anything else you got no
actually uh you pretty much covered
everything thanks a lot go okay you
wanna start the next one
you wanna started cuz you and say you
still oh no no you tell you I don't even
have you you are useless
I just Wow well I mean if that's the way
you feel I won't show up for the next
one bye